[Musique]
le mal règne partout dans ce monde et il
est le fait des humains les humains ne
trouvent leur peau une fois qu'ils ont
épuisé le sol éradiquer les années
hazell c'était de laquelle arrivait
cette chose énorme dans mon rêve
les champs il se couvre 200 quelque
chose m'arrivait de là bas une chose
particulièrement les rangs samuel tu
vraiment certain fever je te le dis dans
les yeux en tant que frère il faut que
tu me crois métal et en vitesse la
meilleure des humains il y à la mort si
tu restes ici ils te trouves ont alors
fui
geste en présence c'était quoi
mais taleo vitesse jamais on déficit
tient là je prends une seule mauvaise
décision
alors je condamne à mort on a suivi
parce que vous avez promis une meilleure
hazell je n'ai rien d'un honneur la
marque des grands chefs
c'est de savoir faire confiance mais de
faire ressortir le meilleur des autres
il n'abandonne pas il reste l'espoir
est-ce que tu as encore assez d'énergie
je ne cherchais peut-être pas la guerre
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas voir ça va être
un immense plaisir de te tuer sa chaleur
tous oculaire
vous êtes battus avec âpreté pour
conquérir votre liberté et sa présence
vous devez vous battre pour la conserver
[Musique]
cet endroit est notre donald duck creek
boutade si je l'abandonné fin